what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be talking about
um something that kevin samuels inspired
me to do um as i told you so he inspired
me to go
to therapy and the reason i decided to
go to therapy is because
um in the next like five to seven years
ideally you know
some things are out of your control but
ideally i'd like to be married
um and when i do get married i want to
make sure i'm not bringing any like past
trauma or any you know baggage into that
relationship and i just want to make
sure i'm in the best like physical and
mental shape of my life
ideally um
okay so i wanted to do like a video
before the therapy appointment but
i totally forgot 100 forgot to do the
before but
my first appointment was really cool um
we just really like got to know each
other and i gave her like
a brief summary of like who i am how i
got here
and we talked about a couple things um
you know that were somewhat personal but
nothing super crazy
but i don't know i have a really good
feeling about this it felt so good
to be talking to a third party who
isn't there to judge you or really do
anything else but help you find
solutions
and help you understand yourself better
and understand other people better
so i don't know it was actually really
cool so i really encourage you guys to
try therapy
if you haven't so far i'm in a bully in
one session so
who knows what'll happen in the future
but so far so good i'm gonna keep you
guys updated